>>> SHE WAS A POLITICAL OUTSIDER
WHO TOOK ON THE DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT.
IN A HUGE UPSET, SHE BECAME THE
YOUNGEST WOMAN EVER ELECTED TO
CONGRESS.
NO, THIS IS NOT A PROFILE OF
REPRESENTATIVE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
THIS IS A WOMAN WHO DID IT 50
YEARS AGO, WAY BACK IN 1972.
ATHENA JONES REPORTS AFTER A
LEGENDARY CAREER IN POLITICS,
LAW AND GOVERNMENT, ELIZABETH
HOLTZMAN IS RUNNING AGAIN.
>> I NEED OUR HELP AUGUST 23rd.
PLEASE COME TO VOTE.
>> Reporter: SHE'S BEEN CALLED A
PIONEER, TRAILBLAZER.
SHE BECAME THE YOUNGEST WOMAN
EVER ELECTED TO CONGRESS IN
1972.
A RECORD SHE HELD FOR MORE THAN
40 YEARS.
HALF A CENTURY LATER, SHE'S
LOOKING FOR A COMEPACK.
RUNNING IN I A CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT COMPRISED OF LOWER
MANHATTAN AND BROWNSTONE
BROOKLYN, AN AREA KNOWN FOR
POLITICAL ACTIVISM.
>> THERE'S A BUNCH OF US
RUNNING.
I'M THE ONLY ONE WHO HAS BEEN IN
CONGRESS WITH A HUGE RECORD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
>> Reporter: SHE PUSHED THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO BEGIN
TRACKING DOWN AND DEPORTING NAZI
WAR CRIMINALS.
>> I WAS VERY DISTURBED TO SEE
THE NATURE OF THE WAR CRIMES
ALLEGED TO HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
BY PEOPLE LIVING IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: HOLTZMAN LATER
CHAMPIONED ABORTION RIGHTS.
>> WHY ARE YOU RUNNING?
>> I'M RUNNING AGAIN BECAUSE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF
OUR COUNTRY.
AND I SAID TO MYSELF WHEN I SAW
JUSTICE ALITO'S OPINION, I WAS
ENRAGED.
AND I SAID I CANNOT SIT ON THE
SIDELINES.
>> SHE'S GOT SO MANY FIRSTS ON
HER EXPERIENCE RESUME.
>> THIS IS TIME FOR SOMEONE WHO
HAS A RECORD OF STANDING UP TO
THE RIGHT WING, TAKING ON THE
RIGHT WING, AND SUCCEEDING
SOMETIMES IN DEFEATING THEM.
THAT'S MY RECORD.
>> Reporter: SHE'S FACING A
CROWDED FIELD THAT INCLUDES A
FORMER IMPEACHMENT LAWYER AND A
SITTING CONGRESSMAN WHO MOVED TO
THE NEW DISTRICT.
HER LONG-SHOT CANDIDACY MET WITH
PRAISE AND SKEFPL SEUFPLT.
-- SKEPTICISM.
>> I AM CONFLICTED.
>> WHY?
>> I THINK SHE'S A FABULOUS
PERSON, A REAL ROLE MODEL.
SHE DID ACCOMPLISH SO MUCH.
BUT THERE IS A SENSE, NOW I'M A
SENIOR CITIZEN, THERE IS A SENSE
THAT PARTICULARLY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, NEEDS TO BRING IN NEW
PEOPLE OR YOUNGER PEOPLE.
>> IS THAT JUST AGEISM, PLAIN
AND SIMPLE?
.
>> WELL, I THINK SOME OF IT.
SOME IS A PRECONCEPTION THAT
SOMEONE MY AGE CAN'T DO THE JOB.
WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE WATCHING ME
CAMPAIGN IN THE HOT SUN, THEY
UNDERSTAND I CAN DO THIS JOB.
>> Reporter: AN AVID KAYAKER,
SHE SAID IT KEEPS HER FIT AND
ENERGIZED.
>> THIS HE QUESTION WHETHER YOU
HAVE THE ENERGY AND FITN